pour ce qui est de l air le sénat
s'était prononcé favorablement dans sa
grande majorité pourquoi parce qu'il
estimait que c'était donc je fais
confiance aux sénateurs et au sénat et
la majorité sénateurs est ce que je sais
ils savent être au rendez-vous de
l'esprit de responsabilité je n'ai pas
de doute là dessus voyez ce que je veux
dire la bienvenue à l'assemblée
nationale
on verra je prêt je présage pas je
ferais offense aux sénateurs mais après
il y aura une commission mixte parce que
le sénat va faire des modifications on
verra tout ça mais je sais que le sénat
dans ces cas-là a été à la hauteur de
ses responsabilités j'ai vu le vote
l'assemblée nationale qui était un peu
confondante côté l air un tiers un tiers
un tiers heureusement
bas comme une absence de ligne la vérité
c'est quand on n'a pas les lignes voilà
ce que ça produit
ça veut dire que d'ailleurs il serait
temps situation de majorité il n'aurait
pas fait voter le pass sanitaire le pass
vaccinale ce qu'ils n'ont pas de
majorité pour le faire c'est comme ça un
sujet pour des gens qui veulent
gouverner d'être à ce point diviser sur
un sujet qui est un sujet
éminent d'urgence sanitaire et donc je
trouve que de ce point de vue là il ya
une petite interrogation qui peut naître
dans les esprits de nos concitoyens le
fond
[Musique]